le retour sur la scène internationale de
la libye souvenez-vous le mois dernier
nicolas sarkozy avait assuré de ne pas
avoir de raison de ne pas recevoir le
colonel kadhafi c'est ce lundi que
débute la visite officielle du dirigeant
libyen quatre mois après la libération
des infirmières bulgares
une visite controversée indigne pour la
france déclare le président du modem
françois bayrou françois hollande lui
dénonce l'aveuglément du chef d'état
français
autant de réactions jugées excessives
par l'ump
mémona hintermann marque ray x kadhafi
longtemps le sponsor du terrorisme
deux entretiens prévus à paris avec le
président français la visite la plus
controversée de l'histoire de la vème
république
mais pour l'elysée rien d'anormal cas
dati coopèrent sur toute la lutte
antiterroriste puisque c'est désormais
un combat commun est depuis longtemps et
toute la communauté occidentale du
renseignement ne peut d'ailleurs que se
féliciter de la coopération des services
renseignements libyen kadhafi soupçonnés
de l'attentât de lockerbie
celui qui a fait placer une bombe à bord
d'un avion français
des centaines de civils assassinés dans
des attentats d'innombrables en afrique
en europe des infirmières et un médecin
torturé jour et nuit pendant huit ans vu
la nature de son régime cela aurait été
impossible sans sa volonté pour ségolène
royal ce voyage est choquant
d'autres ps sont moins regardants la
question qui est posée aujourd'hui c'est
bien que la diplomatie française
retrouve des principes c'est pas le fait
qu'on voit ou non les chefs d'état parce
que sinon on verrait peu de chefs d'état
sur la planète vu le nombre de
dictatures
françois bayrou lui parle d'un voyage
indigne d'un faux l'accord sur les
infirmières bulgares ça consistait en
quoi cela consistait à payer la rançon
la plus immense que tous les temps de
surcroît a donné des armes et en plus à
tirer un coup de chapeau
aux preneurs d'otages vous croyez vous
croyez que ça va sakozy kadhafi s'était
déjà à tripoli en juillet et selon
différentes sources
c'était une récompense contenues dans
l'accord sur les infirmières et la
question demeure pour faire du commerce
avec le dictateur libyen aidé et il
vraiment indispensable de le recevoir à
paris la marseillaise le drapeau son
honneur kadhafi au rêve depuis plus de
30 ans